the state legislative session underway
in Carson City beginning 120 days of
work while today was mostly Pomp and
Circumstance both parties laid the
foundation to what's to come John
langler is live in Carson City with the
story hey there John
Brian good afternoon to you this
legislative session is a bit of a return
to normal you'll remember the last
session was during the pandemic so
everything was done on Zoom this time
though everybody is here and they're
ready to do some business first the
technical items were taken care of
earlier today the members of the
assembly and the Senate were sworn in
leadership posts were chosen no real
surprises Democrats have the majority in
both houses it's a super majority though
in the assembly that means it'll take
compromise to get anything accomplished
with new Republican Governor Joe
Lombardo when early challenge to that
came from the newly named Nevada Latino
legislative caucus it wants to expand
Medicaid to everyone regardless of
citizenship
we believe that many of the folks that
were left behind the covid-19 pandemic
were these community members and so
we're going to be working on uh what the
cost looks like we're in the minority
but I think we're a very strong minority
and with the Republican Governor gives
us what some additional leverage that we
need to get as I said good policy for
the state of Nevada
it's unclear how willing Republicans are
though to even discuss that proposal
from the Nevada Latino caucus in the
legislature education really is the top
priority for everyone here in Carson
City coming up here on 8 news now we're
going to see the opening of the
legislative session Through The Eyes of
someone who's never been here before a
brand new lawmaker here in Carson City
and other expectations for the next 120
days live in Carson City John langler 8
news now John thank you at 11 billion
Governor Lombardo's budget is the
largest in-state history